in 1945 korea became an
almost perfect scientific experiment one
population with the same geography
and culture became two separate test
groups
one capitalist and one very not fault
no matter what metric you use gdp
population
life expectancy education technology
military
really whatever we can now declare south
korea the winner
the north is so underdeveloped that
glancing at a nighttime aerial photo
might fool you into thinking it's the
pacific ocean all of this makes it
tempting to see as a failed state
and even easier to laugh when it
threatens militaries much stronger than
its own
but compare the country not to what it
could be but to what it should
be with the gdp of an african country
you've never heard of and 30
of its population undernourished the
north should be erupting in revolution
even setting aside internal conflict
north korea acts like a younger sibling
provoking his much stronger brothers
except the threat is nuclear war and all
with the military might of tiny belgium
if kim jong-un is just a crazy madman
he's been
incredibly lucky to survive all of this
nobody
rules that many natural 20s life has
never been better for the kim family his
people may be starving and his diplomacy
hostile
but he lives in perpetual we love the
king day
this makes him not a good leader but a
good leader
a master of politics who stays in power
despite everyone working against him
so just how does he do it
[Music]
even the most brutal dictator
prioritizes the needs of his citizens
knowing that a hungry or unhappy
population is a ticking time bomb
counting down to the beheading of its
leader but north korea is a rare
exception
as hungary as you may be you've been
taught that it's no different anywhere
else
revolting would do no good fighting the
only hand that
even occasionally feeds you low quality
of life is not just the unfortunate
consequence of misaligned priorities
is also a beneficial political decision
no one will demand freedom of speech
when they're barely able to feed their
family
people are far too preoccupied with the
latter besides
kim will make personally sure the food
doesn't go wasted
you may hear of coming reform but it's
almost always wishful thinking
kim knows that a better life would
create far too ambitious a population
what would normally be incompetence is
actually political strategy in the case
of north korea
countries may claim only to war in the
name of freedom and democracy but it's
usually
far more complex than that offensive
wars are fought when the inconvenience
of a problem outweighs the cost of war
north korea knows that it can provoke as
much as it wants so long as it doesn't
cross that threshold
and provoke it does kim has shot south
korean soldiers
sunk submarines broken a nuclear weapons
agreement and fired missiles into not so
nice places
these make the news scaring the world
into thinking that war is
coming the media is happy to suggest
that this time
kim really is getting serious when
people are sufficiently scared
kim opens negotiations send us some food
aid and we promise to chill
smart politicians know how hollow these
threats are but
they too are playing the political game
nobody who wants to be re-elected will
ignore what their constituents perceive
to be a threat to national security
but there is a popular alternative
getting tough with sanctions
if a country isn't playing nice you
raise the prices of its goods to anger
its population
this puts pressure on the government who
must behave or risk
revolution north koreans however are
unlikely to turn
on their glorious leader and any
sanctions big enough to actually make a
difference would be blocked by china who
would like to avoid 25 million unskilled
workers entering its borders and the
biggest military in the world
looking over its shoulder the political
mood swings from hard to soft to hard
again
after each policy fails playing soft
only helps kim and getting tough has
little effect
america took a break called strategic
patience but we quickly learned
exactly what that really means still kim
knows this can't go on forever
eventually someone is going to get
impatient and when that happens
things don't look good for an army of
biplanes even if they
are camouflaged so kim plays the
ultimate bomb
card a single nuclear weapon keeps the
capitalist pigs at bay
who have too much to lose from a nuclear
war these aren't the signs of some crazy
ambition
to conquer the world they're a strategic
necessity
[Music]
a chess player is made good by
anticipating his opponent's next move
you're never going to beat a much better
player because he can figure out both
his next best move
and yours too but if you know you're the
weaker player you can stop
trying to beat him by skill and change
strategies
by sometimes making irrational
unexplainable moves your opponent loses
that advantage
north korea does exactly this no
military no matter how much stronger it
may be
wants to risk fighting a loose cannon
with nuclear weapons
and kim knows this when you hear stories
about kim killing his own family with
anti-aircraft guns
pay attention to what that makes you
think about him and then consider how
that actually plays to his advantage
kim knows that he can't outgun america
but he can
lessen their power by being too
unpredictable to mess with
as long as you keep hearing news of
missile tests and pending war and famine
you can be sure kim is thriving
his country may be a failure but his
rule
is anything but